FOX NATION.
THEM ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
INDEPENDENT WOMEN'S VOICE.
GREG GUTFELD IS NEXT.
>> THIS IS PERHAPS THE MOST JOE
BIDEN THING ABOUT FOR SCENE.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN A SENATOR,
VICE PRESIDENT, AND NOAH
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
THIS WITH A LOT OF CHANGE IN HI
POLITICAL CAREER OVER THE YEARS
WITH THE ONE CONSTANT IS THAT
JOE BIDEN REALLY, REALLY LOVES
ICE CREAM.
HE TALKS ABOUT A LETTER TO ALL
THE TIME.
MATTER WHAT'S GOING ON, NO
MATTER IF HE IS A HITTING
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT OR SENATOR
OR WHAT CRISIS US ON HIS PLAY,
JUST GET THAT MAN A COHEN.
HE LOVES ICE CREAM BECAUSE YOU
NEVER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT BRAIN
FREEZE.
I'M BEGINNING TO THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE WHITE PEOPLE,
BUT IRONICALLY A LOT OF THEM AR
WHITE PEOPLE TOO.
JUST ASK LOCKHEED MARTIN
COMBINATION PRESENT LARGEST
DEFENSE CONTRACTOR.
LAST YEAR THEY SENT THEIR WEIGH
EXECUTIVES TO DIVERSITY TRAININ
CAMP.
THE PURPOSE?
TO BREAK DOWN THEIR WHITE MALE
PRIVILEGE.
HERE I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE VIEW
'S JOB.
IN THE CITY JOURNAL, CHRIS
EXPLAINS HOW WHITE EMPLOYEES AR
FORCED TO ATONE FOR THEIR PUTRI
PALE PIGMENT.
THESE WORKERS INCLUDE RETIRED
AIR FORCE COLONELS, GENERALS,
AND ALSO THE DUDES WHO FRONT OF
$1.7 TRILLION F35 FIGHTER JET
PROGRAM.
BUT THEY ARE CAUCASIAN MEN AND
MAKING THEM AS WHITE AND USELES
AS A REALLY BAD LACROSSE PLAYER.
THERE THE EMPLOYEES ARE ASKED --
WHAT WAS LISTED?
CAN YOU GUESS?
RACIST, ANGRY, OLD, ANTI- WOMEN
KKK, GUNS.
BASICALLY HOW CNN DESCRIBED
TRUMP VOTERS.
THE CONCLUSION WHITE MEN DON'T
CARE WHAT WITH THE BIRTHDAY AND
REVIEWS GIVE UP THEIR POWER
COMPANY TO CURE THEM.
THESE GUYS WERE FORCED TO
EMBRACE AND INCLUDE VELOCITY AN
IT INCLUDES THEM IF THERE IS A
PROBLEM.
SOUNDS LIKE KAT'S MARRIAGE
COUNSELOR.
BUT APPARENTLY THE HABIT SO GOO
THAT THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES ONE
SACK TO BE RACIST TO PUT THE
RESOURCE BEHIND THIS SEMINAR AR
ALL ABOUT UNCOVERING ROOTS OF
WHITE MALE CULTURE AND
HETEROSEXUALITY --
HETEROSEXUAL PRIVILEGE.
THE POINT OUT POSITIVE TRAITS
LIKE HARD WORK AND PRINCIPLES
ARE DEVASTATING TO WOMEN AND
MINORITIES.
IF I WERE A WOMAN OR MINORITY,
WOULD BE INSULTED.
WHAT IF YOU IDENTIFY AS ONE.
THE DECK IT OUT OF THE SEMINAR?
SO WE LIVE AT A WORLD WHERE WE
ARE EXPECTING HARD WORK FROM
THAT MINORITIES IS RACIST AND
TELL IT LIKE THAT THEY ARE
INTRINSICALLY EVIL IS AN.
IN PLACE THEN MUST REBUILD THEI
IDENTITIES AS AGENTS OF CHANGE
BY READING OVER 100 WHITE
PRIVILEGE STATEMENTS WHERE THEY
CAN PASS THE APP OF ONE EXAMPLE
OH, I CAN COMMIT ACTS OF
TERRORISM.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT LOOK FOR IN
A WEAPONS MAKER.
IF IT SOUNDS LIKE A CULT
INDOCTRINATION, THAT'S BECAUSE
IT IS A CULT INDOCTRINATION.
ALL THAT IS MISSING ARE THE
EXTRA WISE.
CALLING IT A CULT IS A SMEAR
AGAINST CULTS.
THIS IS BASICALLY A CULT WITHOU
THE BUN STOPPING TO GET THE
HUMILIATION BUT NONE OF THE
DRUGS FUELED.
I WONDER IF CNN IS BOTHERING TO
COVER THIS OR IF IT IS TOO CLOS
TO THE LEFT WING BRAINWASHED.
THAT IS ON THE NETWORK RIGHT NOW
.
>> I HATE WHAT PEOPLE.
I HATE THE SIGHT OF MY WIFE.
I'M A MONSTER.
>> LOTS OF ENERGY THERE.
THE EVIL APPOINTMENT HAD TO REA
STATEMENTS FROM PETITIONS
MINORITIES AND WOMEN THAT
EXPLAIN HOW BAD WHAT AND HAVE
BEEN TO THEM.
ONE OF THEM WAS, CALL, I'M TIRE
OF HEARING IT THE CONCEPT THAT
WE SHOULD BE COLORBLIND.
THAT IS LIKE SOMEBODY HATES
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR TOO.
I HAVE MORE IN GEORGIA --
MORE, WITH GEORGIA WALLACE AND
GEORGIA BOYD.
SOCIETY IS IRRITATING TO OUR
MARTYRED ALWAYS WORRIES AND
EVERYTHING IS A RACIST, THEY'RE
OUT OF A JOB.
I WONDER WHAT OUR ANGRY WHITE
MALE THANKS.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY SEEMS TO
HAVE SEEPED INTO EVERY PART OF
OUR SOCIETY FIND BY NOW EXCEPT
ONE, THE INSIDE OF MY HEAD.
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH HIM.
WHY WOULD LOCKHEED MARTIN GREEN
LAKE THIS IDIOCY.
WHAT DO THEY MAKE?
BASKETS AND FOODS, CUTE HATS FO
BODIES?
NO, IT IS AIR AND MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEMS, FIRE JETS.
ESSENTIALLY THEY SELL THINGS
THAT KILL PEOPLE AND NOT JUST
WHITE PEOPLE, BROWN ONES TOO AN
THEY MAKE BILLIONS OF IT.
AND THEN YOU NEED TO GO CHECK I
THE PRODUCTS.
IT WILL ALSO FIND AS IMPORTANT
THEIR COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY,
INCLUSIVE THIS, AND SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THOSE ARE THERE WORDS.
MEETING WHAT, THEY WILL KILL
PEOPLE OF ANY COLOR?
THE MISSILE THIS DURING A
VILLAGE WAS BROUGHT TO YOU BY --
WHICH IS A DEGREE IN GENDER
STUDIES.
YOU SEE WHAT IS GOING ON.
CORPORATION THE FIGURED OUT A
WAY TO FEIGN THE HARD LEFT IN
AND THE ANTIWAR CROWD CAN BE IF
YOU JUST GO LOW AND PLAY I'M TH
WORST RACE EVER CARD.
IS THE BEST DISTRACTION SINCE
TEXTING WHILE DRIVING.
IT MIGHT BE DISGUSTED BY LUCKY
WITH WHAT IF THE FIGHTER JET HA
A RAINBOW BUMPER STICKER ON IT.
THE COCKPIT IS NOW CALLED A NON-
BINARY --
IN WHICH THE AVIATORS THE
PROJECT ALSO AND IN CITIZENS
FROM ABOVE.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO IS BEHIND LOCAL CULTURE BUT
WITHOUT THERE WAS NO HAD ON THI
NIGHT, BUT I THINK I'M WRONG
BECAUSE THE CORPORATIONS.
HE FINALLY FIGURED OUT HOW TO
PLACATE THE LEFT AND THAT IS TO
THROW THEIR WHITE EMPLOYEES
UNDER THE WATER WILL --
LETTER M A 1 TANK.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND, IS THE
STEERING WHEEL OF HIS 500-FOOT
YACHT.
DOESN'T MAKE FOR BETTER PRODUCTS
?
NO.
THAT DOES IT IMPROVE RACE
RELATIONS?
NOT BY A LONGSHOT BUT WITH A LO
OF MONEY IN THE POCKETS OF
COORDINATORS AND A SMILE ON THE
BASE OF BUILT THE RICH
EXECUTIVES.
LIKE A BOMB, IT MAKES FOR
HECKUVA RACKET MORE WAYS THAN
ONE.
>> WELCOME --
WELCOME TO TWO NIGHTS GUESS.
SHE'S THE ONLY BEACON WE ARE
FREE TO FIGHT US.
MEGAN McDOWELL.
HE'S THE ONLY DALLAS COWBOY WHO
MARRIED A DUDE.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW, ANYWAY.
FORMER NFL LINEBACKER JEFF FOR.
THE SELECT THE MAYOR TO YOU?
PROBABLY POST DOC TANK OPERATOR
A FAVOR CARNIVAL.
FOX NEWS RADIO --
>> HER HARRIS GOLD AND EVERY DA
SHE GETS MORE OLD, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KATHERINE TIMPF.
>> JEFF, I WAS TRYING TO FIND A
FUNNY WAY TO INTRODUCE YOU AND
COULDN'T THINK OF ANYTHING
FUNNIER THAN YOU BE AN NFL
LINEBACKER FOR DALLAS COWBOYS
WHO THEN THERE IS A GUY WHO
LOOKS LIKE LIBERACE.
>> I DID.
THE YOUNGER VERSION OF LIBERACE.
IT'S AN INTERESTING THING TO BE
AT NFL PLAYER AND MARY SOMEBODY
LIKE LIBERACE.
>> WITH THIS WON'T STOP, THIS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, HOW WOULD
IT HAVE BEEN --
HELP WHEN IT UP AND GREETED BY
THE COWBOYS IN THE 1980s IF
YOU WERE SO WE'RE BACK THEN IT
COULD REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS LIKE?
>> IT WOULD NOT HAVE WORK,
ESPECIALLY ON THAT TEAM.
THEY WOULD'VE NEVER GRABBED ME
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
BUT WHEN I DIDN'T GET THERE, WE
HAD A HECK OF A LOT OF FUN.
A LOT OF.
THE NFL WAS OUT OF CONTROL BACK
THEN.
>> SO HAS THAT THE CHANGE?
, THIS STUFF, CAN'T WORK IN
SPORTS OR IS IT IMPOSSIBLE WITH
THAT MINDSET.
>> I THINK IT COULD WORK IN
SPORTS BUT I DON'T THINK SPORTS
WANTS IT TO WORK IN SPORTS,
ESPECIALLY PRO FOOTBALL.
BASKETBALL DEFINITELY NO.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY LONG
TIME AT HEALTH THERE ARE OUT
PLAYERS AND THE NFL AND MLB AND
MAY BE PRO SOCCER.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK THIS
TRAINING ACTUALLY MAKES WHITE
MEN FEEL?
>> I HOPE IT MAKES ALL MEN --
I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
TRAINING FOR ALL DUDES.
I HOPE IT MAKES THEM FEEL AWFUL.
THEY NEED TO BE INDOCTRINATED
INTO WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO BE A
RURAL GIRL.
LIKE SIMULATED MONTHLY CRAMPS
WITH A CATTLE PROD GETTING POKE
UP YOUR REGION.
I PRICED OUT CATTLE PRODS ON
AMAZON.
4.5 OUT OF UP BY PIXAR WRITING
AT AMAZON, A CATTLE PROD $62.98
--
YOU CAN TAKE THAT FINANCIALLY
FOR A CORPORATION OR TEACH WITH
THE BILLS LIKE TO WEAR HIGH
HEELS, JUST POUND THEIR TINY
HOSE WITH A RUBBER MALLET.
ARE JUST TELL THEM SMILE, HONEY
WHY AREN'T YOU SMILING, GET YOU
LATEST HUSBAND LEAVE YOU, TURN
THAT FROWN AROUND.
SO I'M ALL FOR MAIL TRAINING.
>> BUT NOT THIS KIND OF MAIL
TRAINING, THAT KIND OF MAIL
TRAINING.
>> I THINK THAT IS CALLED
MARRIAGE IT BY THE WAY, THAT IS
WHAT TURNED THEM DAY.
HE WAS MARRIED TO A WOMAN.
YES.
THAT HAPPENED TO ME SEVERAL
TIMES.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE YOU MONTH
LIBERACE WITH THAT JACKET.
IT DOES FEEL LIKE A CULT.
>> YES, THIS IS A THING.
TO THE POINT OF YOUR INTRO, I
DID WORK IN --
I STILL HAVE A DUNK TANK WIDE.
THANK YOU.
POINT TAKEN.
THIS IS VERY MUCH A THINLY
DISGUISED WAY OF GOING TO THE
DOMINATRIX.
AT THE SAME EXPERIENCE.
YOU GET CALLED NAMES AND YOU
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE FOR EXISTING.
I THINK THEY'RE NOT DOING IS
PUTTING THE FIGURE OUT ON THEIR
CONTENTS THE SAME THING IN THE
PAST IS CORPORATE CEOS WOULD GE
IN BIG TROUBLE BECAUSE IT WOULD
HAVE THESE EYES WIDE SHUT
PARTIES RIVER BUT IT WOULD GET
THE BOTCH AND GET MAKE IT INTO
BEING DONE TO BE HIS RACIST FOR
AN HOUR AND A HALF OF THE
PROBLEM IN THIS COUNTRY AS WE
DON'T HAVE A WHITE ON BLACK
PROBLEM IN HIS COUNTRY.
IT IS IN WHITE ON WHITE PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IN THIS COUNTRY IS
HAPPILY PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
ARE IN THE PORTS OF MARTIN
LUTHER CHARACTER --
THE OTHER ARE UNDER ATTACK
TECHNICALLY HATES YOU AND WE AR
UP TO GET YOU AND NOT OF IT IS
TRUE.
BLACK PEOPLE, WE LOVE YOU.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME, WHAT
OTHER WHITE GUY IS WEARING THIS
IDIOTIC OUTPUT.
WE LOVE YOU.
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN YOUR JACKET
ON THAT, BUT I GET YOUR PASSION
AND I UNDERSTAND IT.
ALL RIGHT, KAT, SHE SAYS IT IS
MORE LIKE MASOCHISM.
I THINK IT IS DISTRACTING AWAY.
COMPANIES HAVE TO ASEPTIC ABOUT
APPOINTMENT PEOPLE WHO HATE
CORPORATIONS HAPPY.
>> ESPECIALLY IF YOU MAKE
WEAPONS.
I LOVE --
THERE CAN BE NO SUCH THING AS A
WOKE COURSE OF WEAPONS MAKER.
IT IS BEYOND CARING.
ALL OF OUR BONDS ARE MADE BY
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THERE MAKING WEAPONS TO DESTROY
AND KILL.
THERE IS NO, BY ABOUT THAT
WHATSOEVER.
IT IS A VERY BOLD MARKETING
STRATEGY ON THEIR PART, BUT
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS A WOKE
EMMA IS THIS PROGRESSIVE?
WHAT YOU TALKING ABOUT.
>> THE EMPOWERING MESSAGE,
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE BLOWN
INTO MILLIONS OF PIECES KNOWING
GOING TO DID SO IN THE NAME OF
PROGRESS.
YOU ARE A TEST CLOUD.
GUYS BUT BONDS AND GUYS MAKE
PURSES.
SOME GUYS ARE BETTER AT MAKING
BOMBS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF GUYS IN THIS
, NOT MANY WOMEN.
>> YOU ARE KIND OF LIKE OUR BES
THIS EXPERT HERE.
THE COMPANY SLOWLY PUSHED BACK?
TO PUSH BACK YOU HAVE TO LOOK A
WHAT HAS BEEN COMING OUT OF YOU
OWN HUMAN RESOURCES.
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE IT'S
COMING FROM.
IS THAT COMING FROM OUTSIDE CAN
IS COMING FROM INSIDE THE HOUSE.
>> BY THE WAY, DOES A COMPANY
THAT WAS FOUNDED BY TWO, WHAT
GUYS.
THAT IS WHO IS DOING THE
TRAINING AT LOCKHEED.
IT'S SOMETHING INTERNALLY WHO'S
TELLING THEM IN ORDER TO HIRE
PEOPLE YOU NEED TO DO THIS LEVE
OF TRAINING.
IT IS WORSE WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT CONSUMER PRODUCTS BRANDS
WHO HAVE GONE SO FAR LEFT WITH
EVENTUALLY IT'S GOING TO BITE
THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO
ITALY AT MORE THAN HAVE OF THE
CUSTOMERS.
>> CAN I SAY ONE THING YOU?
THEY HAVE TRICKED THE PEOPLE WH
JUST TO LISTEN TO RAGE AGAINST
THE MACHINE.
AND JOINING THE MACHINE.
I'M THE PERSISTENCE.
YOU LITERALLY BUT FROM LISTENIN
TO BEING IN THE MACHINE.
SUCH A GREAT BRACKET.
I ADMIRE IT NOW